hi everyone this is professor and
Science and today we will derive the
energy igen states of a general
two-state Quantum system in another one
of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics two-dimensional State spaces
feature in many important Quantum
systems from spin one half particles
like electrons all the way to cubits
from quantum computers this video is
pretty straightforward we're simply
going to derive the energy IG St of a
two-state Quantum system there's also a
companion video that's linked below
where we calculate the I values of a
general two-state Quantum system and I
actually encourage you to watch that one
first so make sure that you do it if you
haven't checked it out yet so let's go
today we discuss two State Quantum
systems and we're going to start by
considering a general hamiltonian H and
its I value
equation as usual these are the igen
values and these are the IG States and
both are labeled by a plus minus sub
index to indicate the two energy levels
of a two-state
system in the companion video we
considered two different ways of
representing the hamiltonian AG of a
two-state system first the hamiltonian
can be explicitly written in terms of
its Matrix elements like this and to
ensure that the hamiltonian is her
Mission we must have that the diagonal
elements h11 and H22 are real numbers
and that the off diagonal elements are
the complex conjugates of each
other with this form for the hamiltonian
the two igen values are given by this
long
expression second we can also write the
hamiltonian in the bases spanned by the
identity and po matrices like this where
the parameters D are the expansion
coefficients we can also rewrite it in
this more compact form by defining the
vector D like this and the vector of Po
matrices like this also to ensure that
the hamiltonian is her Mission the D
parameters must be real
scalers with this alternative form for
the hamiltonian the I values are given
by this
expression which can also be written in
this more compact form these two
expressions are equivalent and we derive
both in the companion video depending on
the situation one or the other may be
more convenient and you will often find
yourself using either form for the
hamiltonian of a two-stage system so
it's a really good idea to become
familiar with both but let's go back to
today the aim of today's video is to
derive the igen states of a two-state
Quantum system and to do so we will use
this second form of the hamiltonian in
the basis of the identity and the PO
matrices so let's write down the igen
value equation that we're trying to
solve as I've just mentioned in today's
video we will use the expansion of the
hamiltonian in terms of the identity and
P matrices and in this language the igen
value equation takes this
form rearranging we get that D do Sigma
acting on the energy IG state is equal
to the IG value times the IG State minus
d0 sigma0 acting on the IG
State as Sigma 0 is the identity Matrix
this term here simply gives the igen
state and we end up with this
expression this quantity here is a
scalar which we will call Lambda plus
minus this result shows that operating
with d dot Sigma on the hamiltonian IG
States gives a scalar times the igen
states and that means that the IG states
of the hamiltonian are also igen states
of the operator d.t Sigma and the IG
values differ by a constant
d0 overall this result implies that we
can focus on the operator d. Sigma to
determine the igen states of the
hamiltonian and therefore in the rest of
the video we will focus on this new I
value equation where I'm omitting the
plus minus subindices for
Simplicity as we will focus on the
operator d. Sigma in the rest of the
video it is convenient to First write it
out in Matrix form let's first recall
the form of the P matrices starting with
Sigma 1 then Sigma
2 and then Sigma
using these Expressions we can expand
the operator d. Sigma as a sum over a
term proportional to Sigma one a term
proportional to Sigma
2 and a term proportional to Sigma
3 and we can then trivially add these
three terms and obtain this Matrix
expression for the operator D do
Sigma to make progress it is helpful to
make change of coordinates so far our
operator here is characterized by the
vector D which is explicitly given by
these three
parameters we will now change to a new
set of three parameters which we're
going to call D fer and
fi these new parameters are defined as
follows we take D1 to be equal to D sin
Theta cosine 5 then we take D2 to be
equal to D sin Theta sin 5 and we take
D3 to be equal to D cosine
Theta from these relations we can also
calculate the inverse transformation but
we're not going to need them today so
I'm not going to discuss them in detail
if you are interested though you can
always try to calculate them yourself
and for example you should find that D
is equal to the magnitude of the vector
D now at this point the change of
coordinates may appear a little bit
arbitrary and I guess it but I'm afraid
that for now you'll just have to trust
me that it will eventually prove helpful
and we will be able to justify this
better a bit later on in the
video so moving on with these new
variables we can rewrite our operator D
do Sigma the element 1 one is just D3 up
here so using this relation we end up
with d cosine Theta from the element one
two up here we first have to D1 which
using this relation gives D sin Theta
cosine 5 and then we have minus I D2
which using this relation for D2 gives
minus i d sin Theta sin 5 and we can
build the rest of the Matrix in a very
similar way and feel free to double
check this
result next we can rewrite the off
diagonal terms of the Matrix to do so we
first copy the one one element for the
one 2 element we take D sin Theta as a
common factor and we also take D sin
Theta as a common factor for the 21
element and we copy the 22 element as
is remembering Oiler formula we see that
this term here is the exponential of
minus I and this term here is the
exponential of
II so overall we conclude that we can
write the operator d. Sigma as equal to
D cosine Theta th D sin Theta e^ minus i
d sin Theta E power of I and minus D
cosine Theta and this is the new form of
the D dot Sigma operator in terms of D
Theta and
F to find the iing vectors we need now
to diagonalize this operator to do so
we're going to consider the
corresponding character istic equation
which is given by this expression here
looking at the argument of the
determinant we can explicitly write out
the D do Sigma
operator minus Lambda time the identity
Matrix now if we evaluate this
expression we end up with d cosine Theta
minus Lambda D sin Theta e^ ofus i d sin
Theta e to^ of I and minus D cosine
Theta minus
Lambda this means that we need the
determinant of this expression to be
equal to
zero and remember that the determinant
of a 2x2 matrix is simply the product of
the diagonal terms minus the product of
the off diagonal terms and we need to
set this to zero to simplify this
equation we first rewrite the first
product by taking an overall minus sign
out of the second term for this second
product first note that the exponentials
cancel here and here and we can then
combine the remaining terms to obtain
this expression and all is still equal
to
zero let's now make a little bit of room
and let's copy the polinomial equation
that we have to solve to find the I
values the first product here has this
general form which evaluates to a^ 2
minus b ^ 2 we can therefore expand the
first product like this
- d^2 sin^2 Theta all equal to
Z rearranging we get that Lambda s is
equal to this
expression finally note that the sum of
cosine squ and sin squ is equal to 1 and
so overall this implies that the igen
values Lambda are equal to plusus D
which we can also write as plus minus
the magnitude of the vector d
by this point you'll probably have
noticed that we could have actually
derived these results in a much simpler
manner if you remember from the
beginning of the video that the igen
values Lambda are related to the energy
values by this
expression and if you think about the
companion video of igen values we also
know that e+ minus is given by this
relation so we could have immediately
deduced that Lambda plus minus had to be
equal to this expression
but I think that having gone through
this derivation again will prove helpful
as it's allowed us to become familiar
with the new parameters D Theta and F
and this should also make it easier to
evaluate the igen states that we're
going to tackle
next so let's now turn to the igen state
side and let's start with the igen state
associated with the Lambda plus igen
value in this case the igen value
equation takes this form
and we can also write it out in Matrix
form like
this and this column Vector represents
the I
Vector applying the usual rules of
matrix multiplication to the left hand
side we get this for the top
entry and this for the bottom
entry and the right hand side doesn't
change we can now compare the top
entries here and and here and copy down
the equality
explicitly the D terms cancel here here
and here and so rearranging we move all
the terms involving the S one component
to one side and all the terms involving
the S 2 component to the other
side at this point it's useful to remind
ourselves of the trigonometric
identities known as the double angle
formula if you know these identities
Grace and if not you can look them up in
most tables including those on Wikipedia
or on wol from math world and you've got
the links
below specifically we first need the
equation of the cosine of an angle Alpha
which is equal to the cosine s of alpha
/ 2 minus the sin 2 of alpha / 2
considering this term on the left hand
side we can copy it down and using the
double angle formula we can rewrite it
like this
using another very well-known
trigonometric identity that sin^2 +
cosine s = 1 we can combine these two
terms into sin^2 of theta / 2 and we end
up with 2 sin^2 Theta / 2 the second
double angle formula that we need is
that the S of an angle Alpha is equal 2
2 * the S of alp / 2 * the cosine of
alpha / 2 and if we look at this term on
the right hand side we can copy it down
and using the double angle formula we
can rewrite it as 2 * sin Theta / 2 *
cosine Theta /
2 right so let's now make some room and
let's quickly copy the latest results
that we got which involve both the
equation relating the two I State
components and the rewriting of each
term through the use of the double angle
formula inste inserting this expression
into this term and this expression into
this term we can rewrite the condition
that the igen state components must be
like
this we can now cancel this factor and
that factor and we can also cancel out a
term sine of theta over 2 from both
sides here and
here we end up with sin Theta / 2 * s 1
+ equal to cosine Theta / 2 * e^ minus I
* S 2
+ finally from this equation we can
rewrite the I state
s+ to make sure the equation is a bit we
can choose S1 plus as equal to this term
and we get this stop entry for the
column vector and we can choose s 2+ as
equal to this term to complete the
column
vector
so we've just found that for the igen
value Lambda plus the corresponding igen
State takes this
form we could repeat the same exercise
to determine the IG States associated
with the IG value Lambda minus and I
won't go over the derivation in detail
but I recommend that you give it a go as
it is good practice you should find that
in this case the I state is given by
this
expression
great this and this are the two IG
states of this operator D do Sigma but
remember that the hamiltonian operator
obeys a very similar igen value equation
where the igen states are the same as
those of the D do Sigma operator and the
I values are simply related to those of
the D dot Sigma Operator by this
expression and so this means that we can
immediately conclude that for the energy
I value e+ G given by this expression
the corresponding IG State can be
written like
this and equally for the E minus igen
value we have this Associated igen
State and so that's it these are the
energy IG states of a general two-state
Quantum system
Tada let me add a comment about the
mathematical derivation that we've just
gone through so that we can better
justify the change of variables that we
made from the original D1 D2 and D3
hamiltonian parameters to the dtha and
five parameters that we've been using in
most of this video to really understand
the usefulness of this change of
variables you should note that the final
igen states are given in terms of
trigonometric functions of theta over 2
for example here and here and if we try
to write the igen states directly in
terms of the original D parameters the
mathematical EX Expressions would look
actually really complex by contrast they
look actually quite neat in terms of
these new thesa and F parameters and
absolutely the same thing applies if we
try to work directly with the
hamiltonian in terms of the Matrix
elements rather than the D
parameters so overall when working with
the energy ion state of a general
two-state Quantum system it really is
most convenient to work in terms of
these Expressions that feature the Theta
and the and the FI parameters
however it is also really interesting to
mention that most quantities of interest
in quantum mechanics actually don't
really directly depend on the igen
states but instead they depend on
quantities that are built by combining
the igen states for example in the
calculation of the expectation value of
some physical observable and it turns
out that for most quantities of Interest
such as expectation values the final
answers actually don't depend on the
thet over two but only depend on simpler
functions of the Theta and fi variables
and so as a result the final answers
themselves can be easily transformed
back in terms of the original D
parameters or in terms of the original
hamiltonian Matrix
elements so what does all of this mean
in practice for you you will usually use
these expressions for the igen states in
terms of theta and five for your
intermediate calculations but at the end
you will likely be able to write your
final answer in terms of the original
hamiltonian parametes we have a few
videos looking at examples of two level
systems in the links below so do check
them out to see all of this in
practice to finish let's make sure that
we have an orthonormal set of igen
States let's start with an normalization
for cylus we need to evaluate this Norm
in The Matrix formulation we get this
row
Vector multiplying this column
Vector note that the entries in the row
Vector involve the complex conjugates of
the corresponding column Vector which
leads to the change of sign in this face
Factor following the usual rules of
matrix multiplication we have the
product of this term with this term
which gives this
expression and then we need to add the
product of this term with this term
which is simply sin s of theta / 2 we
can cancel this exponential with that
exponential and so we end up with the
cosine 2 of theta / 2 plus the sin s of
theta / 2 and this of course is equal to
one so our initial S Plus igen state was
already normalized which is
great I would now encourage you to
repeat this same exercise to confirm
that s minus as we wrote it is also
normalized and spoiler it is but it's
nice to to double
check finally we can also check
orthogonality which amounts to checking
that the overlap between s+ and S minus
is equal to
zero to finish we have the final
expressions for the igen values and igen
states of the hamiltonan of a two-state
Quantum
system as a final note remember that we
can always multiply a Quantum state by
an overall face Factor without changing
the physics of the problem and therefore
you may often encounter these igen
States written in one of many possible
Alternative forms but you should always
be able to relate them back to these
Expressions that we've derived today the
energy IG states of a general two-state
Quantum system take a particularly
simple form in terms of trigonometric
functions with these results you can now
tackle for any conton problem that's
defined in a two-dimensional stay space
and we have several examples in the
links below as always I hope that you
liked the video and please
subscribe